the number one thing in social media
that I'm most excited about now is
something I called brand forance I would
much rather every video I post get 17
views 100 views but then if I really got
it give me1 million as you know Tik Tok
is the closest thing to that all the
algorithms on every platform I'm going
to follow Tik Tok cuz it works it works
cuz it's more based on Merit now meta is
going down that direction Instagram's
going to do that you're seeing it in
YouTube shorts which is why I've been
saying it Facebook's fan pages they're
starting to do it as well so the model
is put out as much as you can different
it hits now you know that people
resonate with it now you take it back
the original video and you change the
copy you slightly tweak it and turn it
into a right hook put it out organically
it hits take it back add to the copy or
slightly tweak the copy to make it a
transactional piece of content now and
then run $500 worth of ads against that
it's going to work because the creatives
already shown to you because the
algorithm now is not based on people
it's based on interest so you know the
ad is good